es cierto que el derecho internacional
ha sido vulnerado pero esto es una
práctica estándar de los grandes poderes
cuando se tratan de sus intereses de
seguridad y en este sentido lo que rusia
ha hecho es alterar la ecuación de
seguridad en europa que hoy tenía una
preeminencia principalmente occidental y
donde rusia ha decidido trazar un punto
una línea de detención de ese avance de
occidente hacia europa del este- esto
tiene consecuencias como bien se dijo lo
que estamos viendo justamente tal vez es
el trepidar es son los últimos momentos
de de las expectativas acerca del cambio
que podía generar el orden internacional
liberal sobre todo en europa que se
había construido a partir de esta idea
internacional liberal para pasar un
orden mucho más particularista y acorde
al ciclo 21 que está basado
principalmente en un nacionalismo
centrado en grandes poderes no nos llama
la atención
de rusia es una conducta tradicional en
los grandes poderes que os asociamos al
siglo 20 pero que porque sea el siglo 21
que no ha dejado de ser importante sino
que también sigue esté jugando este
juego de alta política juanes o en
cuanto a rusia pero tal vez la pregunta
que se hace la comunidad internacional
es qué pasa por la mente del presidente
putin qué es lo que desea lograr el
presidente putin con estas incursiones
con esta tensión con washington con esta
tensión con bruselas ignorando las
advertencias y pasando por encima de la
ley internacional que es lo que quiere
putin
es la pregunta del millón ya que quiero
ser muy prudente en por respeto a la
audiencia acá hay una situación de
guerra lo que estamos viendo lo que
estamos tratando de decodificar todos es
si va por toda ucrania si es una
operación de cambio de régimen similar a
la que se enfrentó a la que se hizo con
irak en el año 2003 o si las ambiciones
de putin son mucho mayores yo te diría
que ucrania es el cierre de un ciclo que
comenzó allá por el año 2008 cuando
lanza su primera operación ofensiva en
el cáucaso contra georgia y que esa
primera operación ofensiva terminó
justamente a 20 kilómetros de de de
tbilisi y que dio origen a osetia del
sur la pregunta es que vos haces es
clave pero no está claro desde el punto
de vista de cuál es el próximo paso de
putin yo creo que cierra una una etapa
que se abrió en el año 2008 y de ahí en
adelante las cosas como bien señalaba la
profesora están cambiando y eso lo que
estamos apreciando